前回の主題も作っとき失敗してたらのエロいローソンってなったんですけれども
正直でねっ作者悔しかったスっぽい子ドクター始めとしては実験で失敗は許されないん
ですよそれから和えたものを使って確実に僕は成功するために
ちゃんとんレポートを作って完璧な状態で今回は超巨大さでも確実に迅速に完璧に
作ろうと思います
まずちょっと前回の反省線から説明します前回の失敗点まるいち
皆さんお気づきの通り水を入れすぎた水が多くなんかどうしてもトロトロになっちゃう
それがスライムが失敗したローションになった原因の
ちょっと考えられますそして兄点目ペンタ県道リっと水は前混ぜてなかった
洗濯のりは一度ポリビニルアルコール pv えってやつ使ってるんですけれども水と
死んだけどしっかりまず内の部分的にその混合した水と pva の物質だけがその
工場を入れたときに固まっちゃってしライブのできるところがこうなんか転々とし
ちゃって量も多いですし完璧な左右にならないんですよ部分的にスライム
水に大澤リードそれそれにならないしそういうわけでこう絶対的に細分
十分にならなかったのも原因のひとつでありますそれにこれ4散歩発作飛びついたけど
正式名称は放射ですからそのば自分でネットと過去いろいろせラインについて調べて
わかったことが2点ありますひとつ目水と pva の割合ですライブの柔らかさが
決まります出来れスライムの量が10%と仮定した場合
水タイプ
tv へ洗濯糊ですね水大川隆法が6.5たい3.5の場合柔らかめのスライムができ
ますまあ全開で僕は餌と水が8で pv がにぐらいで作ったねあんな
なったんですけれども3世代 pv がゴータイ語の場合2のとろっとしたスライムが
できると水たい pv が3.5際6.5点取るがちょっと多めですねその場合固めの
スライヴができます今回はちょっと安牌をとって仙台の両名の固めた細胞を作ろうと
思いますすみませんちょっと科学者として本気出すんで完成車スライヴにその後
コケッコー実は全解放者を入れて男性
関西たスライムに固くならないかなとけど絶雪たしても変化がないんですよ
3月米の割合でもうずライブの方下がらずは確定するんでそれのほうしゃをどれだけ
出しても変化はありません
伊豆を踏まえという上でね本気でやりますよ悪いんでちょっと
理系だしてください者ってできるじゃないですけど元に系ですけど
先日の用品で
前回菜箸で混ぜていたんですけどあればなめすぎね外だとかですっかりまんですねオン
ゴッドしっかりつける
当初ですね余分目に2つ買ってきました本気です
や加工明るい未来のためにね字と黄色でオレンジ色の債務を作ろうと思います
ガチだぞ
白癬としてはまずこの4本入れると出会えたボトル2本分に水を入れて簡単なまでは4
体にするんですよ選択ないと水をトータルの混合物を柱として考えると
まぁだいたい割合的には水が3.3333
てダブりが6.6のブログなんでまぁだいたい6.5たい3.5で近い形で今回はを
やります
ある
移動
がまで姿見せる-8
[音楽]
あーあーりんぐほどうぞ
r
で pv 8時完了ですま一応こんな感じです次にこの日本
これで量的には4体になりますそこに水入れても投入します
がちだとんぽう名ウェイウェイめっ
うぇいメリーはやべえッー
想像
じゃねぇなんだこれそう
食べればしまっ
パッチンポンチョコーンウェイポーン
みずみずポコッ全国へとね pot しろあの
できてがも飛ば趣味なんでまだ内緒です勝ち混ぜだよ
方者はだいたいでいいんだよ
ダイナにいっかちょっとぬるめのお湯は準備しました
なんで舐めかっていうと大澤解きやすいようにですいただいていただきたい
ん
[音楽]
スザンそろそろ縁でます
ん
これはなかなかえっ
ただ混ざってくれ
思った
うおおおっおおっ
次は肇社長の論文です
蘭世嘘どうぞ
というわけで
なんとか終わりました作る過程まだすすげー
のフィールドに召喚しようと思います
いいけどもし何かべちゃー止まったらどうしようそれでは良い
これが俺のスライム毒の
限界なんですよ
そのまぞ床にこぼれた耐久だろう
じゃあ行きます第二が退去したくないんだけど
またよまあいいやいい
no o
[音楽]
俺だ
ああスライバーよけれちょっと待ってスタッフやばやばいやばい
ちょっと待ってちょっと待って待って待ってちょっと
[音楽]
ブーブー
んすみません悪い子じゃないんですけどずつラインが出来ましたので
まあね科学っていうものは失敗を繰り返して成功するものですよ
n
ちょっと待ってなんだなこれなんとか
スライは作れるんで
ん楽しいあの
親に怒られないレベルでスライムをつくってみてください
成功って感じで良かったしちゃう
じゃあな
いっ
ちゃんと配慮すランク空校
これから耐える勝手に洗い小谷クラッ
こうやって家に帰すんですよ
骨から入っちゃダメだって